a wie oder was geht hier so adriani und
ich hoffe mit meinem brüssel hieß es
mein bruder und ich spielen heute schon
wieder kam minecraft weil das treffen
kann und dachte ich mir du kannst es
nochmal wagen und mal was anderes machen
also es hat mich definitiv gefreut dass
so etwas anderes kommt gut ankommt
deshalb hier wohnen was once a
das ist jetzt kein geheimnis spiel sowie
das letzte aber es ist einfach was fast
wir voll gerne gespielt haben früher und
ich finde es auch ganz lustig weil da
immer so paar kleine aufstiegschance
passieren aber wir wären einfach mal aus
ich werde ich glaub ich nehme den erd
oder wald ist der schnellste
die donau jedes mal wieder das an sich
ist das so dass das spiel heißt hätte
glaube ich oder eins gegen eins fußball
und du musst einfach hüpfen und den ball
irgendwie ins tor köpfen ich weiß nicht
viele von euch kennen das wahrscheinlich
früher war das bei uns in der
grundschule immer so wir haben das im
computerraum gespielt immer wenn ihr im
computerraum dann haben wir irgendwie so
so was geschieht einfach weil keine
ahnung dann wenn der lehrer nicht
geschaut hat dann dürfen wir auf
miniclip oder spiel affe oder sowas
das mit den pfeiltasten und wsd richtig
und losgehen und es geht los seid ihr
bereit als will ich erst mal die falsche
richtung gelaufen
und als müll heißt sein
ja es war ehrlich und igor nein ja aber
ich bin froh dass ich genauso sein
ich erwarte da rossi okay was okay aber
platz gemacht am nächsten liga brachte
die augen zugemacht und falls ein
bisschen schild wenn du wirst mir das
nein nein na ja da kommt der verloren
geht dass der kopf gewonnen
nein das klar nein
scheißegal springt ja im kopf via fax
richtig dass vor dem kleid
ich darf vor allem die steuerung sei
investor ein junge der immer weiter ich
habe vor allen dingen gerade gedacht die
steuerung sei invertierte weil ich
wechsele ich hab's wird die andere
richtung gilt land aber mein 11 euro
wolltest durchgezählt zeit vorbei 12 das
sind ja vor die kurzen spiegeln kann man
kann man kann das aber tut man es länger
stellen und diesmal bin ich älter bin
ich ja noch nie wieder
die video kann man es mit mama drei
minuten drei minuten verspielt ist ready
jetzt genommen jetzt geht es um alles
mit mirjam bringt endlich power
ich glaube dann kannst du merkst du
stärker drücken usa steigen lassen ein
junge das ist nichts weiter als auch
nichts man kann es überhaupt nicht
kontrolliert
du kannst über wien konzentrieren
kontrollieren kann man es nicht besser
sie einfach so auf den kopf springen
kannst und der leute aussteigen
ich könnte gar nicht wegdrücken warum
bin ich die denn so klotz ja ich wollte
diese auf den kopf springt die ich dann
so richtig kriege wie die gespräche
seien für die eine oder auch ihr partner
können wir behinderte band wie in so
einem hinterhalt ja ja der geist nicht
ist es nimmer gemacht
ich mache mir eigentor als das duo
welches schießt ja was heißt nein das
eigentor verlängert meine schüsse nur
weil die fakten dangerous sind die zeit
dazu alters okay jetzt aber jetzt
problem und nach richtung gefällt mir
gar nicht scheiße wir aber nicht wie
dieses alles was du heute gefühlt hast
da gemessen das sind so möglich hp bot
der junge habe ich letztens in der 80
ja ich glaube auch playstation gefertigt
das macht sich gut ist ein konto das
geld überweisen
dadurch gerne ruhm aber kann es nicht
denn die tasten playstation deutschland
gefehlt
falsches attribut das liegt daran dass
sich an ihn denken
ich habe mittlerweile auch einfach so
momente wenn ich so komplex kindes bin
dann sage ich immer dass lustig
kontrolle über mich soll's jetzt gerade
ein exorzismus nötig auch gott ist der
schnee jetzt gerade also so umgestaltet
werden dass akkus gesehen hoops
professionalität lässt grüßen
ley soundcloud richtig wollen wir noch
ein letztes jahr jetzt werden komplett
komplett unterschiedliche ich werde
endlich mal ein komplett unterschiedlich
nehmen und wie ramos abgeht
aber irgendwie gelockt keine ahnung
warum
wenn ihr bockhop dass wir dann waren mal
wieder so ein spiel socken zum beispiel
baumann gab hat man früher auch immer
gespielt so schreibt in die comments ist
wollen wir so spielen bei diesen
komplett gegensätzlich okay ich bin ich
egal wir werden sehen
ok dort wird sich der die komplette
genommen
arme sau durch kennt nur am pc durch
kein frau nach abwägen speed weg vom
torlinie
insgesamt 110 oder 112 aber ist immer
gewonnen
02 02 ich weiß nicht leicht sagte mal
die kommentare hier wäre es 1 gemacht
ach ja aber zwischendurch zeit
aufgenommen
johanna was hat es denn lukas interesse
junger es ist nichts und auch namen und
ich glaube wald bleiben wir stehen wie
springers jetzt mal nur die auf dem kopf
das in dem das ding mache ich doch junge
lassen ihn nicht vorliegen spricht
drüber
ja dann ist da noch erwischt der
eigentliche sind allerdings auf deinen
kopf alter ich so wir könnten werden
endlich hoch springen würde ich mit mir
anlegt wenn man sich den fuß gebrochen
hat erhält nach den bankenmarkt voller
absicht oder nicht angekommen
für sie gibt es mitunter fresse nicht so
können die leute gehen ja cool
durchführen 134 fiktion wurde sagen wir
13 der herzen 85 auf dem score nicht
darum gehen die veilchen vorgemacht hat
das ist nicht so leicht mit dem für
gerade für mais steuer 5 zu 1 junge
wasser steht für mich bestimmt überhaupt
planen liegt dann nicht nur weil die
leute sehen können ja aber ich war
fertig als er schon einige player aber
wir haben doch die support aufnahmen
zwischendrin ein etwa nun also das hat
es denn nicht aufgenommen so 1500 liter
naja ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
obwohl das ein bisschen kennt es ja
fällig war
aber ich fand das lustig noch mal was
anderes abzunehmen und ich habe keine
ahnung was für den krassen kontrast an
sein muss wegen ganz unten stehen
aber das was man heute noch gut
schmeckt man